Alejandro was the dead man was he who never
He got home
and he was going to go directly to work
I play like when one says what
they riddled him because he did nothing
and now we feel with this
sadness
says then we come here to give to give them
a news says that alejandro no longer
is with us because the police says
he killed him says why
I was this
with a gun a gun says and it
they were forced to shoot
but all your load 13
shot us all and returned to
charge and kept shooting
the most terrible thing for me was to hear from
that the policeman saying that when
they turned around he was still alive
and he was drowning in his own blood
that was that it was really terrible for
me to hear true
that they should not have killed my son
they must have talked like when
when they talk to people who do not
they are the ones that are not Latinas
simply when they are white